[Music]
and marketing fail news submitted by you
know nothing you're not laughing no
chill I know everything I just make it
up
Delta passengers were creeped out by
flirtatious Diet Coke napkins mm-hmm
locations not litigious oh it's like
it's like give a coke to someone sexy or
some [ __ ] like that [ __ ] I've seen that
oh it's like [ __ ] me if you want to lose
weight
wait what that one yeah she's not far
so these napkins were under that Delta
airline and they were handing out these
Diet Coke napkins and this is what they
said because you're on a plane full of
interesting people and hey you never
know and then it has a space remember
and then the creepy part of it Joe was
here be a little old-school write down
your number and give it to your plane
crush you never know what's what's
creepy funny people that creeped out cuz
there's like yeah back in the day we
didn't want unsolicited phone numbers
either and you know those people like
this a couple the napkin you throw away
you just take the napkin in your nose
but the memories when people wrote down
their number and they passed it to you
like it was [ __ ] elementary that's
pretty cool yeah well what are people
mad like how dare you be sexually
harassing me with the [ __ ] Matthew
enables and you raised me that's what
I'm saying you like I feel like it's
these people that are like our complaint
trigger-happy the blue haired people
right if you have you because in the
movies a goal like this we could know I
wanted to do it we're in the movies they
have the lipstick they did it and
integral XOXO that was really nice
oh she needs to be kissed that way I
will just do it now I do it like this I
go oh my god that's how I kiss Maddie
anyway I give it a try it was really
spiky to see this little she likes this
I just felt like I got kissed by a
walrus I was gonna say what did you find
Oh a cactus
oh I just got soft kiss bye
you guys are so flirty with each other
cactus honey kisses Maddie yeah it's
just like I kiss me Maddie like that
it's like yeah it's army yeah they're
getting it on me yeah she thinks a Wiley
Wiley coyote when when she gets horny I
[Laughter]
don't know cactus yeah transfer like
kids you just give it to the leg no
continue this channel but you try to
make the world
you gotta move the bill no he needs you
to take charge oh all that buildup
thank you I was playing the game of
being the lady of the relationship man
huh cuz you were a pants huh yeah yep
you guys wear the same pants I heard we
do yep it's not because she's fat it's
cuz I'm feminine I'm so embarrassed
anyway back to the napkin so someone
tweeted out like anyone else see these
awful Delta in-flight Diet Coke in the
awful awful there's a spot on the back
to put your name and phone number to
give your point how dare you be a F oh
my god [ __ ] Oh dare you [ __ ] uh
promote romance you [ __ ] animal baby
you own where everyone's on their phone
to try to get like matchmaker calm
Christian mingle all this [ __ ] like god
forbid someone writes the thing on a
napkin I know why can't you be like a
decent human being and go on tinder yeah
forget basic basic human interaction no
crazy how much it shifted cuz I remember
back in the day would be like why you
mid that person online that was
embarrassing I'll show you here always
yeah it's weird if you didn't mean
online I feel like this is gonna be
whoever's complaining about this I feel
like it's not a lot of people it's
probably a couple but I feel like the
type of person doing this is the type of
girl that like she's kind of like the
fat one that always tries to stop her
hot friends from getting the numbers you
know at the bar she's just like no sorry
we're busier we're going or you know he
was trying to rape you girl yeah
annoying loud one well obviously it was
enough people complaining though because
they did pull these napkins oh Lord
well you know why all of those girls
with Twitter now they care all together
but dude it's always like [ __ ] maybe
80 people maybe yeah and then every
while these companies overreacting
because there's not enough people
celebrating it so then all these I mean
it's hard to celebrate it's not that
great of a marketing yeah most normal
people don't give a [ __ ] here's my
theory about the internet right
the most vocal ones in real life or the
least vocal minority right because
regular pupils they don't write that
many comments all over the place yeah
and have an opinion they're just they're
kind of lurkers I think most normal
people they're like think they learn
other people driving creating the
content like crazy people are making
content yeah like us but you know what I
mean like like regular people
they're just watching this is just a
marketing campaign like hello yeah
that's what this is for that's why they
did this is to get people talking about
it right for Valentine's or something
right right you know who cares so
another one another tweet said pretty
sure no one appreciated unsolicited
phone numbers in the good old days and
they sure as heck don't want the numbers
of someone who has been gawking at them
on a plane for hours today oh no someone
gives you a number oh yeah unsolicited
numbers on the attack now you know it's
crazy cuz I we're not Virgin Airlines
you could actually send another seat a
message whoa like if you thought someone
was cute or what everything but oh like
they encourage 47b
hey what's your name and you can talk
and you could talk to people so what do
these people think about that thing they
don't fly Virgin Airlines a flight don't
even know about it oh yeah it's not
easily easy to read in one flat surface
that's the [ __ ] whole thing about all
this [ __ ] that's why it's totally a
marketing point you know you know
something I just realized I'm a part of
outraged culture you're a part of you
original I'm outraged about the people
that are outraged let it go yeah I'm
like why why you so outraged about
something so small you look at [ __ ]
we're the snowflakes yeah I'm snowflake
about the snow for the blue haired
people you were the blue they're people
yeah about the blue haired people
because we wouldn't have JK news if we
did an outrage about the snowflake
people we have to so now we're these
special people yeah it comes full circle
but we're doing it for the greater good
though it's different but there are
bigger [ __ ] than us that's what I'm
having yeah we're small [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah tiny ones really small and
super tight very tight [ __ ] yeah a lot
of viscosity there
that is not a viscosity finger no you
need it you need it you need it Jess you
actually to be thankful for the word you
should be thankful for the word
viscosity is very important it reminds
me of the biscotti cookies on Delta
Airlines excellent those are amazing do
the nice and song in the grocery store
yep
that's not the same it tastes different
to me it's got to come like in that
little [ __ ] packet mm-hmm and it's
got to be past you and it has that
little Delta assigned and you have to
open it right when the person to your
left of you farts they're like oh it
gives a certain flavor on that cookie
says Delta to my memories [ __ ] me
Delta stamped I thought I thought the
cookie had a Delta logo I thought so
anyway so Delta does a rep said this for
sure equipped we rotate Coke products
regularly as part of our brand
partnership but missed the mark with
this one
we are sorry that's and began removing
the napkins from our aircraft in January
I which song would just come out and say
suck my dick [ __ ] yes why can't it say
Delta Airlines it's like are you all
[ __ ] serious question mark don't be
so sick especially if they didn't do
anything wrong huh there's nothing
violent
you shouldn't apologize nothing
offensive about this nothing illegal and
then they have to get out there and say
we missed the mark I know it's the mark
so not only did no I just want them to
say shut up you [ __ ] sensitive [ __ ]
well coca-cola also apologize for taking
cocaine out of the drink I should
apologize about they said we sincerely
apologize to anyone we may have offended
we work with our partners at Delta to
begin we worked with our partners adults
we'll begin removing the napkins last
month and are replacing them with other
days I bet you the [ __ ] people that
complain about it don't even didn't even
realize that apology came out and they
moved on to the next thing
I can't believe [ __ ] macaroni
and cheese is yellow I think that coke
has realized something that I wish these
guys would realize a long time ago which
is like nobody wants to [ __ ] hold
this up and talk about it right
like nobody's look gives a [ __ ] about
sugar water people like
aren't gonna talk about your product and
get it viral and all the [ __ ] you have
to create some kind of a thing that gets
people to talk about and then they get
coconut hand and then go get a cup
because did you know that pop bad
publicity is better than good publicity
and that's why Trump won that election
true because he knows how to get into
people's brains and be relevant be
persuasive everyone everybody keeps
talking about all theory like that Kim
card the whole Kardashian back yeah the
most hated family in America and also
probably the richest yeah like Jesus
they're so smart because they know how
to get into people's brains they know
how petty we are mm-hmm I am petty
conjugation that's how we emphasize how
petty I am I'm Patti I like the Eiffel
Tower and then petty with the EAD you
should have a meter and it's all the way
full and I says this is how petty oh
yeah hey no I don't don't give me that
cure no I just want to stay petty you
know I want to be riddled with it I want
to I want to [ __ ] get my panties all
up in a knot I like where the snowflakes
are you yeah I wear her thong and then
my ball sacks hang from the side you
invent a thong for balls and I hike it
all the way up like this and I [ __ ]
put it on like suspenders and then you
show and then you be like hey just come
look yeah okay
I'm gonna marry you yeah she's like good
damn I didn't know about this before I
met them and then just that word
viscosity comes into play right yeah
[Music]